هذه هي الطريقة التي تتعامل بها الفنادق مع
النقص في الموظفين ، حيث يرغب الضيف في الحصول على
مشروب غازي يتم توصيله إلى الغرفة ،
وسوف يتعامل هذا الروبوت مع المهمة التي صممها
سيليكون فالي سافيك ، حيث يكون روبوت الترحيل
جاهزًا لتسليمهم في هذا النوع من
وضع الأزمة حيث  يقوم
الموظفون ذوو الأجور الأعلى بملء
الأشياء التي يمكن للروبوتات بصراحة القيام بها ،
يحتاج الروبوت إلى التدريب مرة واحدة فقط
للتنقل في الردهة والممرات حتى
أنه تم تكييفه لاستدعاء مصعد
بمجرد دخوله يمكنه الضغط على الزر الخاص
بممرات الفندق المخصصة للطابق  يمكن أن يكون
التنقل خادعًا حتى بالنسبة للبشر الذين
يمتلكون سيارات التدبير المنزلي والضيوف الآخرين ،
لكن من الجيد حقًا الالتفاف حول
الأشخاص والنظر في كيفية تعامله مع
الردهة المزدحمة بمجرد وصوله إلى الغرفة التي يتصل
بها الضيف للإعلان عن وصوله ، حيث
ينتظر روبوتنا في الخارج  بابك
لتلتقطه يفتح الروبوت باب
حجرته ويوجد المشروب الغازي الذي طلبه الضيوف ، وقد خفض الروبوت
خدمة الغرف من 30 إلى 5 دقائق  في
كثير من الحالات ، تقلل أيضًا من القلق المغطى ،
فهناك ضيوف يعجبهم
حقيقة أنه يمكنهم الحصول على
عناصر وليس لديهم هذا الاتصال
مع الإنسان ، ومرة أخرى ، إنها تج
بة محسّنة أكثر من استبدال شخ
روبوت تحت الطلب 24 7
ليس لديها أيام إجازة أو تأخذ إجازات
في أخبار sunnyvale david lewis abc 7